The global elite are gathering at the
World Economic Forum in Davos,
Switzerland.
The annual meetings first winter event
in three years.
And the ski town attracts CEOs,
billionaires and celebrities for a week
of discussions on income inequality,
climate change and so much more.
Now this year's theme, Cooperation in a
Fragmented World.
But the event does often draw criticism
for attracting the ultra rich who
pontificate about global issues without
really committing to fixing them.
Your inaction is fueling the flames by
the hour.
Show me the money.
Talk is cheap.
It turns out that nobody is as generous
with your actual dollars as they are
with their pledges in their press
release.
We can talk for a very long time about
all these stupid philanthropy schemes.
We can invite Bono once more to go.
We got to be talking about Texas.
That's Texas, Texas, Texas.
All the rest.
In my opinion, one area where we might
see some movement is on the breakdown of
panels during the last World Economic
Forum.
A third of the panels were devoted
specifically to ESG and the use of words
like environmentalism.
In those Davos press releases has
actually tripled since 2014.
Sometimes who's not there is more
interesting than who is.
Former president Donald Trump is not
attending, nor is current President Joe
Biden, an embattled crypto entrepreneur.
SPF is obviously out, but there will be
plenty of panels on the future of
digital currency.
So Paul could take on all social
platforms to get updates on the World
Economic Forum on the ground in Davos.